it's time to wake up sky people so
listen up season six of the hundred is
well underway
and we can't wait to find out about the
brand new world our heroes will be
exploring we've got some of the wildest
season six theories lined up for you so
don't go anywhere
you won't believe what a planet with two
suns can do season five recap before we
take after our heroes and travel into
the unknown let's jump right into a
short recap of season 5 the episode
Damocles part 2 ended with a bang and we
have McCreary to think for that luckily
Clarke Bellamy and all the means managed
to get out of shadow Valley before earth
faced its second nuclear bombing but you
best believe that when Heda got her
revenge before boarding the spacecraft
with little time to spare everyone who
remained urgently boarded the ship
before it went blasting off into space
all of Earth's survivors except for
Monty and Harper were put into a deep
sleep but little did they know that over
a century would pass before they would
regain consciousness again by the end of
the episode we find out that Harper and
Monty are long gone but they've left
their son Jordan in charge of the human
race I'm Jordan
Monty and my person Clarke and Bellamy
are the first to wake up and they soon
realize that everything has changed
our heroes are last seen gazing out at
the new planet that lays before them the
season 5 finale was designed as an open
ending which left us with plenty of
questions
it was fashioned this way in case the CW
decided to pull the plug on the series
luckily the hundred was later renewed
for another season the new ruler let's
start off with the most obvious theory
but an exciting one nonetheless it's no
secret that humans crave leadership so
this brand new planet is bound to have a
ruler of some sort
and since Clarke and Bellamy are
natural-born leaders we can expect them
to bump heads with whoever is in charge
of the mysterious planet after doing
some digging it was revealed that actor
jr. born would be portraying a visionary
named Russell this character is said to
be a peaceful ruler who's determined to
keep the new planet safe and sound so
what's not to like
right still we've received that Clarke
and Bellamy will start challenging this
leader sooner or later but Monty did
his old friends to be good be the good
guys
so perhaps our heroes will go to the new
planet with open hearts or perhaps
history is about to repeat itself once
more
a common theory is that the new earth
will appear to be perfect at first only
to start showing its true colors will
this Russell character turn out to be
who he says he is
we highly doubt it our theory is that
Russell will drive a wedge between
Bellamy and Clarke
whereas Bellamy will want to believe in
the Oasis Clarke will have her doubts
and let's just say that one of them is
right and the other is wrong some people
won't be waking up at all although it
may be sad some of our favorite
characters are predicted to sleep their
way through season six Bellamy and
Clarke were the first to wake up and now
they're tasked with venturing onto an
unknown planet and determining if it's
safe enough to live on it makes sense
that only a selected amount of people
would be chosen for the journey after
all waking everyone up at the same time
and telling them that a hundred and
twenty-five years have passed doesn't
seem like the brightest idea some fans
believe that Keene won't be making an
appearance for most of the season the
former Chancellor was severely injured
in the season finale but his injuries
were put on hold when he fell into an
induced slumber actor Henry Ian Cusick
who plays Keene confirms that he
wouldn't be a main character throughout
the sixth season during the Television
Critics Association press tour
Henry confessed that he'd be busy
filming for the new TV series the
passage however he reassured fans that
Kane wasn't dead just yet some fans
believe that Kane's awakening will
happen much later in the series if at
all in the end some sleepy characters
might be put on the backburner to leave
room for the newcomers but they should
all wake up in due time the unknown
planet the sky people spent their entire
lives studying the earth before ever
stepping foot on it and now they're
about to land on a planet they've never
even heard of Landing is going to be a
huge risk especially since they don't
know what they're dealing with fans are
curious to find out what the planets
landscape will look like after all it's
rumored to have two suns so it's bound
to be beautiful animators are surely
going to do the planet justice so that's
definitely something to look forward to
when Monty and Harper realized that the
earth was dead they set their sights on
a different horizon
they found out that Eligius 3 had
actually been responsible for locating
habitable planets and not for finding
oil like they were previously led to
believe
so Monty chose to retrace the
Corporations tracks with hopes of
finding a suitable planet to land on and
here's where things get interesting fans
are convinced that Eligius 3
successfully landed on this planet all
those years ago and that now Bellamy and
Clarke are about to meet the descendants
of this ancient interstellar spaceship
if this is the case there will be plenty
of new characters joining the production
we're not sure what's going to happen
once our heroes touch ground but we're
expecting to be hit with a heavy dose of
action bye bye echo echo is a fierce
warrior but does she have what it takes
to survive season 6 of the hundred fans
don't seem to think so echo and Bellamy
have been going strong for a while now
that is if you don't count the last 125
years of course the couple is said to be
very much in love which is why we can
expect to see a lot more from echo
throughout the beginning of the season
however some fans think that echo will
be killed off shortly after coming clean
about her life story
although echo is a very likable
character Bellamy isn't supposed to be
with her so we're just waiting for her
to get booted out of the picture but
come to think of it the last thing
Bellamy needs is to lose another person
that he loves so for his sake we hope
that he and echo will break up before
she kicks the bucket a fan named Bellamy
Stan took to Reddit to say the following
echo will probably survive but I hope
she won't make it although this sounds a
little harsh we can't help but
understand where he's coming from
after all Bellamy's got bigger fish to
fry could the mysterious Russell be the
one to blame for echos alleged death
we'll just have to wait and see old
wounds will heal Bellamy and Octavia
have a very complicated relationship at
one point in time Bellamy was
responsible for keeping his sister's
existence a secret so when they were
shipped off to earth he continued to
protect her which got super old super
fast
so much a redditor named in canto
one-two-three posted an interesting
theory online and it has everything to
do with Octavia healing her wounds and
becoming who she used to be this fan
believes that Harper and Monty's son
Jordan is going to fall in love with
Octavia and vice versa so why pair these
two together well because they have so
much in common
Octavia spent the first 17 years of her
life with close to no human contact on
top of that she was forced to land on an
unknown planet and help the human race
prevail sound familiar
well that's probably because Jordan is
about to go through the exact same thing
these two characters are predicted to
click come season SIG's finding love
again and watching someone else go
through what she did might help Octavia
heal some of her wounds Bellamy and
Clarke will become a thing we know what
you're thinking yeah right well you
wouldn't be the first person to feel
this way and anyone who's read the
hundred book series knows that Clarke
and Bellamy have been an item for ages
in fact these two characters are
actually engaged to each other fans have
been aching for these two leaders to get
together for a super long time and
they're growing impatient
the fans are certain that bill art are
going to become a real deal come the end
of season six
if EKKO does indeed pass away the midway
through the season this would give
Bellamy enough time to mourn her and
maybe just maybe you could start to see
Clarke in a different light
but anyone who's read the novel's knows
that the TV series follows a very
different course
so some fans are choosing to be
skeptical Clarke and Bellamy clearly
have some work to do but if all goes
well fans predict that a two son wedding
is on the horizon the sacrifice every
season demands a sacrifice and it looks
like a certain characters number is
going up in flames fans are taking to
Reddit to converse about possible
theories and there's one that keeps on
resurfacing Andra might be a fan
favorite but according to redditors
she'll be the next to go
Andra is a fearless warrior who has the
ability to inspire bravery and loyalty
although she wasn't too fond of the sky
people at first she warmed up to Octavia
and chose to fight by her side
fans predict that indras oil tea will be
put to the test and
you'll choose to go against Octavia
however she later find out that she made
a mistake and beg for her friend's
forgiveness
unfortunately Octavia won't be in the
forgiving mood so to prove her love and
devotion Indra will sacrifice herself
for the young leader during a battle and
her debt will forever be repaid what do
you guys think is it time for Indra to
lay down her weapon
or not Jordan season six of the hundred
is going to be filled with brand new
characters and material not only our
skilled explorers going to be sent down
to an unknown planet but Jordan will
experience life for the first time this
fan theory sort of changes the course of
things especially since it puts Jordan
on the front line so in other words move
over Clarke and Bellamy because there's
a new sheriff in town
if there's one thing fans are sure of
its that Jordan is going to be treated
like a child for the majority of the
season and oddly enough he'll be acting
like one too but all this will change
and soon he'll become a leader like his
dear old mom and dad when it comes to
taking the reins Jordan might be the
best guy for the job
no offense Belle arc but you guys are
sort of violent the goal the twin planet
to say that we saved the best for last
would be an understatement because well
this theory is simply amazing a reddit
user named brothel in came up with an
interesting theory that we just can't
shake according to him the Tube moon
planet could very well be populated by
clones he went on to explain that Eliza
Taylor who plays Clark revealed that
season six would be the most challenging
one yet on top of that this season was
also described as Clarke heavy so fans
believe that Eliza will be challenged
with playing to different personalities
and perhaps the entire cast will have to
do the same if the new world is indeed a
twin planet things are bound to get
intense do you think Russell will use
his clones to his advantage if so he
might be keeping them at bay to prepare
for an old fashioned switcheroo so which
one of these series was your favorite be
sure to let us know in the comments
section below if you loved a hundred as
much as we do make sure to give this
video a big thumbs up and don't forget
to hit that subscribe button for more
awesome videos to come your way thanks
for watching and see you next time on
the things
[Music]